[Music]
you've done like a billion of these
already
well then stop clicking on them try not
to laugh
challenge more like try not to get this
video age restricted
copyright flagged try for the love of
god to get ads on this video challenge
let's go
i'm gonna hit you guys off with one of
my favorites it's a classic
obviously i've seen it does samuel l
jackson like anime
yes i do hentai too
it's so [ __ ] good there's one there's
another version let me find it does
samuel l jackson like anime yes i do
hentai too
why is samuel l jackson me a true
american hero no roy
but god has given me a power even
stronger than the world
nah it was
all right oh wow this is gonna be weird
[Music]
what just happened why did he stab
himself
why was there an american woman trying
to read japanese
so far i haven't even flinched have you
laughed yet
you best not because then you lose
you don't want to lose do you that's
right
moving on i think i've seen my friend am
i
pregnant yes i have but it's funny am i
gregnant
am i pegnate help is there a possibly
that i'm
peg rent am i pregnant or am i okay
could i be pregonate how do i know if
i'm prengan
can i be pregnant can u get pregante
can oobleed while ooh or pergert can u
down a 20-foot waterslide pegnat how can
i get
my gf pregnant what happened when get
how can a nine-year-old get pregnant
will my get
pragnan what is the best time to sex
to become pregnant does anyone know how
many teens get
brigant a year are these systems of
[ __ ] pregnant brigant
[ __ ] brigant jesus how long does it
go on
me and my boyfriend are trying to get
prefnet and
haven't took my birth control in 12 days
38 plus 2 weeks
pregnant reganant
ah congratulations everyone
we're pregnant you're [ __ ] our art
these people need to not pass on their
genes
they need to get sterilized i'm all for
sterilization
based on grammatical errors
[ __ ] i've seen this one as well it's
goddamn beautiful
goddamn why are you killing my job
killing
[Music]
the best part about this one is his mom
his mom tells him to stop
okay come on guys stop stop making the
kid cry
stop it
all right guys all right guys stop
stop making my kid cry in this video
game jesus
hey man it's probably just a glitch dude
it was a communist man it was
he pulled the communist card god bless
president obama will go down as perhaps
the worst president
in the history of the united states
exclamation point
at real donald trump well
at real donald trump at least i will go
down
as a president
when you open your heart to patriotism
there is
that music is going to copyright me it's
goddamn beautiful why
curb why that's goddamn beautiful that's
an
excellent meme okay okay yes uh butt
plugs
please
butt plugs i have a bad connection i
don't understand
what is it uh butt plugs bug box
is it like a receptacle butt plug butt
plug
butt plug butt plug yeah butt lug
butt plug i know but what do you use it
on what do you use it in i'm trying to
plug butt plug
yeah okay i got you a spark plug there's
all kinds of spark
butt plug butt plug
butt plug
nut plug god bless that man so innocent
bless his heart
whoa oh what
seems pretty realistic to me that looked
legit
if only i was alive at the time of real
battles
you sit at the restaurant with your
young son
he says he is hungry you agree to get
him dinner
you open up to the kid's menu this is
just become try not to razzin some
challenge
what the child is far too young for
adult food
chicken nugget stares at you from the
page
you don't understand your palms get
sweaty and your son complains
he says he's hungry your mind
strains searching for an answer in a
world of sweer potato
and french fried you try to order the
chicken nugget but you cannot
the words cannot escape your lips
your son is hungry the waitress stares
at you her
head a spinning chicken nugget her arms
swinging french fried your son
cries the tears of a chicken nuggets
child
in your mind you scream it is
raining sweer potato now you have french
fried engraved on your left temple and
you do not understand
your son weeps in the corner he
is starving starving
for the chicken nugget
no one noticed it said sweer potato as
well jesus
i love chicken nuggets my favorite dish
there's no shame in ordering it even
though
you're an adult and it's on the kid's
menu
[Music]
my precious power ring
forever
voice acting 101 that's amazing what an
incredible shriek of terror i
i truly sympathize with this woman oh my
god yes i've seen this one
ah i don't even know if we can show this
oh it hurts it's bad
[Music]
hey
you can do it
for your brothers
[Music]
we never heard of panty shot lover 64
after that moment rest in peace
this has been try not to laugh challenge
did you laugh or did you lose did this
get copyright strike
most likely thank you for watching leave
a thumbs up
and as always sister fister my sisters